let's talk a little bit about growth and
profitability as private public markets
this is
kind of the story of um
i guess the last year since uh softbank
came in and splashy cashied all over the
place
uh grow from growth and profitability
obviously uber uh
got hit pretty hard lyft got hit pretty
car after going public we were collapsed
everything's since rebounded what do you
guys think about this transition from
growth at all costs in the private
market staying
private until you have billions of
dollars in revenue as opposed to 50 to
500 million um
and then the public markets saying we're
not interested well it's been a
bummer that i haven't had the
opportunity to invest like you have
because i was waiting and waiting and
waiting for some of these ips
never has the private market versus
public market difference been as
extreme or clear in terms of who can get
in and where and what those companies
look like then right now
you've got so it's unfair in a way that
retail investors can't get access to
these companies earlier
yeah you guys are eliminated we applaud
kind of some of the exchanges
that are like pitching right now to
figure out ways for companies to be able
to go public easier because
it is a fairness thing i mean i agree
like wealth creation doesn't come from
getting a paycheck it comes from
investing in things and owning things
and it's a shame that some of these
amazing companies you know
by the time that they finally go public
they're going down that's such a
disappointment i mean that would be i
was just bummed
it arguably would have been so much
better off uber to have gone public
two years earlier had the conditions
been stronger
and maybe mature the company in a
different way faster which company
oh uber uber yeah uber went public when
it was 10 billion or 20 billion and
people could ride it up from 200 cities
300 cities to a thousand
and i know you're connected with travis
but you know maybe if there was
different public pressures on travis as
opposed to what the vc community is
putting
on